why was audio so important I like to
understand why audio is so important for
blingiest
is first you have to understand
commuting in traffic jams so this is the
Dakar version of a traffic jam because
we're New York I thought maybe we also
look at the human version of a traffic
jam maybe let's do a quick you a who a
few commutes more than 30 minutes per
day like this like most people what are
you doing are you consuming content when
you're commuting who's listening to
audio when they commute other question
like five years ago did you listen to
audio when you when you were commuting
so that's very interesting because we
started as a text-only company or just
producing text content and we started
speaking to a lot of customers so text
Catholic worked well we kept growing but
not like crazy growth so we started
talking to customers to understand are
we missing something in order to really
convert most of people to the
subscription or to retain those
subscribers for longer so we started
talking to a lot of people in the US
because the US is naturally our biggest
market we are a German Berlin based
company but the US was a biggest market
from day one and what we realized is
that a lot of our customers and users
would tell us that hey I like what you
do but I don't have time to read
blinkers I already have like I'm reading
the New York Times or The Wall Street
Journal I don't have time to read
blinkers but actually I'm commuting
every day 30 minutes an hour like two
hours and I won't would have time to
listen to continent what we love to
learn something new when I commute in my
car or like in a subway but there's no
product or there's no offering which
really helps me to learn something new
and this this clear insight really
complex truck with us saying oh look
there's like there's the need people
want to learn something new when their
commute but there's not a real good
chance for them to do that because
there's not a real option for them to
you to acquire new knowledge when
basically yes they say the hands are
busy but the mind is free so you can't
really read because you're like moving
you could listen but there is no option
for that so what we did is we talked a
lot about that so having this clear
inside normally you would say well like
go off and try something out and just
build a product and see if it works back
at this point we were maybe 15 people so
it felt like a very big decision for us
to say okay we're gonna
produce we're gonna stop producing audio
content we're gonna change the product
from a text-only product to an audio
product and as it is with these big
decisions we can't kept pushing off this
decision for a while at some point we
were sitting in a room six seven people
and we talked about a topic of audio
again and at this time growth had slowed
down a little bit in terms of like new
subscribers we said okay it felt like a
case no or never either we try all you
know we will never have a chance to try
it again so we are sitting in this room
discussing the topic of audio again and
I don't know really what what change but
suddenly everyone was like super excited
saying yeah that's right let's just do
it
so we went often said okay let's try
audio let's make a plan but what's very
important is that we try to do this a
very structured way so we Betty said two
principles or we created framework for
us that said first let's be very clear
about our goals and expectations of
audio and second let's make it very easy
for us to get out of it if our
expectations are not met so what the
first one means is let's be very clear
what we expect from audio is we said
okay first it's gonna increased
usability of the product which means
more people are likely to convert to
blinkers because there's no like a room
like there's a time when they can use
blinkers and therefore they would
convert to the product second we thought
with audio the perceived value of the
product might be higher so we could
actually charge more for blinkers then
we could charge before in terms of make
it easy to get out we said to ourselves
okay instead of investing like a million
to that building a new team hiring
people let's do a different approach
let's find a couple of people within a
company that are super excited and
passionate about audio let's give them a
little bit of like just create an
outline of what we need in order to go
to the market with an audio product and
then let's give them full autonomy let
them run and figure something out and
what they will build over like three or
four months we're gonna launch and then
see if already works so what we did
we're just five people like across the
company one person from content one
person for marketing one person from
tech all excited about all your they
were like musicians or like podcast
aficionados back then and we said okay
here's like a small budget we need 50
audio versions to launch that we need an
audio player and yet you have like three
months
try it out and they just like because
they were so passionate and motivated
like excited about it
but you didn't need to motivate them
they were just basically working like
crazy for three months because they
really wanted to move forward with the
audio and this is really how we could
like set up audio to test Ferrari
without like any new hires and we still
were the company of 15 people and we
basically creating a second product I
probably didn't have before so end of
2014 we finally launched all units just
like three months after we made the
decision so like a decision we kept
pushing off for like nearly a year
because it felt like such a big project
and such a big commitment and in the end
we were able to make it like make it
happen within three months and as George
said this like this launch changed the
trajectory of the business and of the
company completely and I think is like
the main driver for the revenue growth
we have seen in the last three years it
grew revenue or like it was so important
for like the business side for two
reasons like what's so important because
increased the lifetime value for
customers tremendously and this mostly
for two reasons the first one and this
is an old screenshot but what you can
see we introduced a new subscription
tier called premium we were not as smart
as the guys at tinder so we didn't pay
too much attention on naming we just
said we had PLAs and Freeman this one's
really cool if I had to make decision
again I probably would do it differently
maybe something like gold and so now use
the number one we are we are like we're
trying but well what is like important
we said okay as I said we wanted to
increase prices we credit create a new
price here which was way higher than the
initial priced here so it wasn't what a
50% more expensive than the initial
price - we had before and what's also
important is we also raised the price
for the non are you priced here so just
to make this clear premium includes
audio plus didn't include audio and we
also had like a pin feature connect to
Evernote so we increased the price so
the price for premium was 50% higher
than the initial price and we also
increase the price for the plus
subscription which didn't change at all
was the same subscriptions before but we
felt like now the product has like a
higher perceived value so we increased
that price to
which is yeah just like when really was
really well really important for us in
terms of like increasing lifetime value
maybe you know time pricing and how we
arrived at these price points is pretty
there's no magic behind that we
basically just look at comparable
products like headspace back then and
looked oh they charge around $80 per
year we were like charging $40 at this
time so we're like basically under
priced compared to other products so
let's just do $80 as well because what
we learned is that pricing is of
relative it's not really people it's
very hard for you to kinda like say what
like to say okay I'm willing to pay this
amount of money for this this type of
value I'm getting from this product but
what people are very good and edit at
are is comparing so they say oh I pay
$10 for Netflix per month and I get like
unlimited movies and series which is
$120 per year so I pay $80 for blankets
where get maybe like unlimited book some
recent text an audio that sounds like a
fair deal so this is how we get go to
the price by just looking what our peers
are charging and go with this price
point because this is what people would
expect so that's the first point why it
really helped creasing lifetime value
the second point in this very obvious as
well it just increased retention because
audio created like a new way for people
to consume content at times where there
was no competition back then so people
who used all your stick around for
longer and therefore renewals increase
in their for lifetime value increased
today audio is completely like the like
really at the center of the whole
company and of the product so we have
the audio product which is like the the
main way how people consume content
today at blinkers we launched podcast we
have like one really well working
podcast called simplify with more than a
couple of million of downloads where we
talk to book authors about alive and
about ebooks we also have actions for
Google assistant I think this is how it
called right I don't call it skills that
would be would be like another company
just like the way we think about all you
like always really the center of all
products we built now and are just also
a big big topic for innovation of
pinkest
so in the blinkin style so that's the
story of how we
got to audio how we started and I tried
to distill it kind of like the key
messages from this talk and what are we
doing at playing is this we distilling
the key insights for books I try to
distill the key insights from this talk
and the key message of this presentation
is and excuse me for this very long
sentence but you might know the Germans
like long words and long sentences and
have to read it because user centric
product innovation can help you to
unlock value by expanding your value
proposition Laura you should have liked
warned me before this is like what I
mean but it is like I think it's very
important when you think about like new
building new product and try to like do
innovation that you focus on your
customers listen to your customers try
to understand their problems try to find
needs that are not served yet rather
than approaching this from a business
side saying oh yeah it would be cool if
we had debt and then try to build it and
then try to charge more for that that
won't work but if you really try to
understand customers and what they are
facing or promise they need what they
have and what you can solve then this is
a good opportunity to introduce this and
also increased prices which then unlocks
value for your company and for the
business the first one the bleep number
1 of this presentation is the impact is
hard to estimate beforehand so as you
see for audio we can push it off then we
said ok we do it we didn't know if we
kind of what's gonna work out or not so
what we knew is there is a need for
audio but we didn't know if link is the
right product in the right solution to
serve this need so you could like we
could discuss this for 4 years we did or
just try it and I think it's important
that you do research but I believe
strongly in that use at some point you
have to trust your intuition or like
listen to your gut saying ok if like I
collect a little of data I look at that
but then you have to make a decision
based on that so what we do at blinkers
we call this data-driven intuition which
basically means we we collect data but
the data won't give you the answer you
have to still like to make a leap of
faith at some point because you will
never have perfect data to make a
decision and sometimes timing or like
often timing is super important so one
thing when it comes to audio blink is
what is important is when you look at
when we launched audio it's like end of
November 2014 so we were working for 3
months so we started in September
working on audio in October 2014 the
serial podcast was launched and serial
podcast like in hindsight is probably
the podcast that opened up audio again
for like a whole generation of or like
for like basically everyone and that's
very interesting because like we didn't
create his trend but we were like
basically at the same time maybe
arriving the same insight or like just
there at the right time because suddenly
all you was the thing and everyone was
looking for audio products without
serial I'm not sure if blinkers or you
would have been dead successful to be
honest but you can't you do you don't
know before and you just have to try
that so timing obviously is important
but without trying you will never be
able to capitalize on trends
the second key inside here is start to
learn by doing
keep the downside covered so I think
what we try to avoid is just building
business plans and just like you're like
creating these extra sheets and then say
yes or no but say okay there's like your
thesis we have let's test it but let's
test it so that we have two downside
cover let's not say we don't invest in
the whole team we build a lean
experiment with what we think is needed
to validate that and then rest we run
with that and then we see if we want to
double down on it or not and I think for
us this comeback squat that we use
assemble of these five people was really
crucial for for the success of the
project because these people were
passionate about it so they we didn't
need to motivate them saying hey you're
working on this now please can you come
and make it happen
they made it because they wanted make it
happen and they spent all the time doing
research about all your they spent all
the time like going into the details to
find a really really good already
experience they spend all the time on
figuring out like fixing all the box and
the audio player so we had a really good
product for first version but still in a
very lean way the third insight is where
it comes surprising users often create
your own pricing analogies for your
product so as I said before you can be
very scientific about pricing this might
work look I don't know we never tried
that for us what worked is just looking
at the market and like finding
comparables because this is what in our
experience people mostly make pricing
decisions based on they will look what
other products are charging and now
based on that they will come make a
decision if your product is cheap or
expensive of course if you're in the
market where
maybe there's no comparable product and
you can make in a very good position but
if you're an entertainment education
there are a comparable products and the
default comparable product for
everything that has to do with content I
feel as either Spotify or Netflix
because this is what people always
compare you to in the end because they
know what value they get there and if
you try to be much more expensive than
you have either you need something very
very exclusive or very very small market
niche where people say ok I need this
for my profession and I'm paying for
whatever whatever is needed or you try
to come kind of stick within the frame
what other companies are charging the
last inside link number 4 is be ready to
fail even the best ideas can fail so as
I said like we didn't know if art is
going to be says success or not was it
was successful but of course you can
fail and we had another big experiment
like we believed strongly in community
at blinkers we like talked to customers
again and we we thought we heard them
telling us hey would be cool if you
could have like sharing features and I
could comment and I could share with
them blink kissed and we thought cool
because the business is very interested
in the two so if we had like a viral
growth component at blinkers we might
grow faster and we don't have to invest
that much money marketing so I think in
hindsight was more like the business
side speaking and us just hearing
something we wanted to hear what
community we we launched there we we
worked like six months on this and it
was like the for me diverse feature we
ever launched probably because we didn't
really pay attention to our customers
but more like to the business interest
and it failed spectacular so that can
happen and I think just you can learn
from that and try to do it better next
time what's very important yeah as I
said like we ready to fail therefore it
start small don't bet a whole company on
one on one idea but just find a way to
do it in a way that yeah you can always
exit easily without like making like
making it hard to get out of it thanks
you